Hey guys, it's 2025, okay? It's 2025. What are your dreams for this year? Um, that I may- God, I don't know what kind of tone to take with the coffee chat because like what if it's like, you know... You can go balls out literally. Really? I can start cursing right now? Yeah.
Saying bad words. By the way, the shorts I'm wearing, I could go balls out real easy. Wait, Will, stop it. You don't know this person yet. Oh, you just set the balls out of your. No! Oh!
Don't show us your balls. I'm not going to. How dare you? All right, now listen. Oh, now listen. Now listen. Hang on a second. No, no, no, first of all, don't go to your script.
What are you talking about? I have. You've been working on this. I saw your eyes go to your script. Let me see your material. No, now here's my thing. No, I was gonna say that Jason missed Willie's birthday last week, we missed you.
Yeah, thanks man. How'd that go? But listen to this, I told Will, I was gonna say this on the show to you, Jay. You can never make fun of me for, well you can, for my eating habits and my diet. This fella right here at his own birthday dinner. He's a real shit pig.
Brought, but Jay, he brought his own Hershey's caramel syrup. First of all. In his pocket, in his pocket, by the way. And then I asked if I could have it. You dropped some nice weight for this film. You're gonna be 420 in a week. No, no, no, no, I'm still on one cheat meal a week. By the way, I didn't bring it in my pocket.
I made Archie, my 16-year-old, put it in his pocket. Bring it, he muled it. I had too much shame, he muled it in for me. Then Kimmel said, is that your tanning lotion? And then, by the way, so everybody made fun, at which point they bring Sundays out for everybody, and every person asked for it. Yeah, that's a good call.
It was amazing. Everybody had individual Hot Fudge Sundays brought to them. Well, it's like when you drive past a car crash, you're going to look, you know, but you don't want to. I guess so. It's human nature. But it was just so rich watching people making jokes. Look at you with your camera, get it over here, okay?
Yeah. And then I tried to, you know, cause I missed it so then the next day I texted Willie on the day of the first Maple Leafs game on the next round. And I said, hey, I feel bad, I'm gonna fly into town and I'd love to see you. I'm gonna pick you up at five.
Now five o'clock was when the puck dropped. He didn't, he's so, I know he didn't know what I was, what the joke was there. He was just like, oh, you did or you didn't? Of course I knew what the joke was. Really, because I did it on game two and you still didn't get it. I don't get what the joke is.
The joke is like, you must not be busy. Yeah, I need to see you right at the point that the puck drops. Oh, I see, I see, got it. Yeah, can't be talked to. Yeah, no, I did. And, but anyway, yeah, the Leafs, who knows what's gonna happen when they go forward in this
because this will be way later. Oh yeah, but we've got a real series now. We've got a real series. I was in Toronto this weekend, I did my hospital gig for the Michael Garan Hospital. We raised millions of dollars for the hospital, which is amazing. That's so great. We love, this is the hospital I like to be in.
Do you still take lira? Do you still take lira? Michael Garren Hospital, we take lira. That's really funny. I have 600,000 lira here, two dollars. Remember, it used to be like 100,000 lira for two dollars. Yeah, I know, there's nowhere else to go and you can get like $100. So that's unfortunate that it didn't time out with the Leafs being in Toronto, right?
They were playing down in Florida. They were playing in Florida, but I watched with the whole family, my dad and my sisters and everybody, we went to our pub, The Queen and Beaver, which is James and Kerr, which I'm also a part of. That's a rough title. The Queen and Beaver, it's pretty good.
The Queen and Beaver, yeah. And it's a great pub if you're in Toronto. You ever sub out that N for an S? Queens? Queens? Queens Beaver? Oh, the Queens. Oh, oh, oh. Add an S, not take an N out.
Oh, you take a Queen and Beaver. Queen and Beaver. Queen apostrophe N Beaver. You take out the apostrophe N, you put in apostrophe S, the Queen's beef. Well, here's, first of all, it's and, it's not the. I'll meet you at the Queen's beef. It's not Queen's beef.
I had the greatest meal at the Queen's beef. God, what did you do? Wait, that's the joke. The joke is. It's kind of salty there at the Queen's beef. Wow. Guys, my guest today is a father of six. He's deeply offended.
No, he won't be. He's a father of six, former soccer hopeful, football. His resume includes washing dishes in an Indian restaurant and once cooking lunch for Princess Diana. These days he's got a soft spot for In-N-Out burgers. I just had two yesterday, which is a true story. Two, you needed two? I did, I got two, I ate them in in my car let me check out the believability scale
on that by the way and some of the beef fell in between my seats and I had to get it out because I knew it would smell if you had to suck it out I did with my straw first time you suck beef out of seats sorry gang at the Queen's Beef. At the Queen's Beef. That's a different one. The Queen's Beef is next door. We went for dessert at the Peach Crease afterwards. Guys, we're losing listener by the moment. I know, sorry. He has an obsession with cold plunges, Will.
You love that. And a few Michelin stars under his belt, all while turning, swearing into a love language. Today he's bringing the fire in and out of the kitchen. It's the wonderful and delicious Gordon Ramsay, who I've loved forever. Guys, just met him a couple weeks ago with you, Willie. Wait, what? We just ran into you, Gordon.
What are you talking about, where? Yeah, over at our friend Bradley's place. Yeah, that's right. Oh, I didn't know that. Now, how do you all know each other, Willie? How did that all, that wasn't the first time you met him? No, we met through our friend Bradley's place. Yeah, that's right. Oh, I didn't know that. Now, how do you all know each other, Willie? How did that all, that wasn't the first time you met him. No, we met through our friend. Gordon, we're going to let you speak in a moment.
Rob Wade, right, Gordon? Gordon, we had dinner with our friend Rob Wade. That's right. Guys, good to see you all, and thank you. Great to see you. Wait, this is amazing. I've never met you, Gordon, and I'm a huge fan. And meanwhile, I didn't know you knew these two guys.
Yeah, catch up, Sean. I'm here, that's why I can't wait. Gordon, this, and I'm a huge fan. And meanwhile, I didn't know you knew these two guys. Yeah, catch up, Sean. I'm here, that's why I can't wait. Gordon, this is what I want to know. Thank you so much for being here. You're such a good dude. Where are we finding you right now? Because you're always, every time I see you, you're always coming from the airport
or going to the airport. No, we've got the up-fronts today, so in New York. Oh, people still have those, even though the network television business is kind of. Fuck me, yes, unfortunately. They do, they do, and they're painful. Oh my God. The first one I ever went to, so for Tracy,
the up-fronts are where networks put up their shows, they display kind of what the fall season's going to be and the ad agencies are going to commit to ad dollars. They pre-sell all the commercials. Right. And now streamers are doing it too. I'm on my way there for Netflix. Oh wow.
So the first time I went to Gordon was. See you there, Gordon. The first time I went to an upfront, I was like, can't we handle this into a fax machine? Like, can't we just send an email saying like what the shows are? And why do you have to like the dog and the pony of it? And how were the laughs to that joke? Can we handle this into a fax machine? Like, can't we just send an email saying what the shows are? Why do you have to like the dog and the pony of it, right?
And how are the laughs to that joke? Hey, listen. No, it wasn't a joke. I was serious. Like, can't we just, why are we on it? First of all, Gordon is keeping, single-handedly keeping Fox on the air. I know, that isn't true.
That needs to be said. That needs to be said. 20 years. 20 years. 20 years in 2004 we came over. As you know, there was not many mainstream foodie programs on the network. And how many shows in 20 years? I think we've, is it 10, 11 or 12?
Wow, that's unbelievable. It's unbelievable. Good Lord. It's really impressive. I've watched every single episode of Kitchen Nightmares. Stop it. I love it. Stop it. For real, I really have.
He's obsessed. I love it so much. Has there ever been a celebrity edition? Could Sean be on a celebrity edition? How do I get yelled at? Please don't open a restaurant, Sean. Please, please, please don't. I got a good name for it.
The Queen's Beef. The Queen's Beef, Jesus Christ. That's the problem. That's the one big problem in this industry that anybody can open a restaurant. It's not like an actor, it's not like a doctor or a lawyer, a bar school. I go back to that dinner party when they say,
hey, Sean, your food's fucking delicious, man. You should open a restaurant. So the next day, you start looking at taking leases out in the neighborhood for these incredible little bistros. And then that reality turns into a nightmare because they sort of, they don't fully understand that it's a business. neighborhood for these incredible little bistros. And then that reality turns into a nightmare because they don't fully understand that it's a business. Like I'm just going to cook for my friends and other people will like it too. And pardon the pun here, but have you cracked what maybe the secret sauce is to keeping a restaurant open?
Because I would imagine when it first opens you need sort of to be somewhat of a popular restaurateur where you've got a certain client base that they're going to come in and they're going to populate it for the first week, month, whatever. And then of course the food's got to be good and that can carry you for another couple of months. But how do you get into years after years after years? How do you keep it hot and fresh?
Yeah, great question. First of all, you need to keep it local, right? The secret of any great restaurant is filling it Monday to Wednesday. Thursday, Friday, you need to keep it local, right? The secret of any great restaurant is filling it Monday to Wednesday. Thursday, Friday, Saturday, it takes care of itself. And so that's the essence of getting it right. Filling it Monday, Tuesday, and Wednesday nights. Especially in the middle of November and early into January.
So stay local, okay? Keep the produce simple, don't overcomplicate things. And don't go crazy on the prices. Because it's a lot easier to make money on alcohol than it is on food. overcomplicate things. And you've just got to know your market. You've got to really know the market. And you've got to know how to, you know, so we all jokes aside, so the Queen and Beaver is a gastropub in Toronto that my friend, James and Curve started and he was a restaurateur.
So he had another restaurant and then he opened a few and including the Queen and Beaver and the Oxley. Now he runs exclusively Queen and Beaver and I have a small interest in it and have since the beginning. Oh, say it one more time then. But that is his business and that's what he does, right? That's his full-time thing and he runs a business
and we're in the penny business. So we have to count everything and everything matters and everything is locally, we make everything in the restaurant, all the bread is made in the restaurant, it's well-priced and the menu's very good and it's very simple. Again, it's just a gastropub, Queen and Beaver,
just above Dundas, open seven days a week. But that's the thing, but like Jason was saying, after all those years of, like, cause I go to this restaurant, we all have our favorite restaurants. One of mine ends in, well, Jason's like, it's McDonald's. No, it's, I love Chin Chin, but no. And after years and years, how do you find the energy
and the passion to maintain and sustain that restaurant? Yeah, I think it's important to change the staff every three to four years, so that I get complacent and lazy. I've been a great motivator of planning succession as well. This industry is an absolute bitch, and it's notorious for the burnout. And so when I start to spot that in the team, it's time to take a bit of a sabbatical and move them on.
Restaurant Gordon Ramsay this year celebrates 28 years and 25 years at Three Star Michelin. So that's... Wow, wow, that's amazing. That's in Chelsea, a tiny little restaurant. What's it called, say it again? Restaurant Gordon Ramsay. So I decided-
Oh, restaurant Gordon Ramsay. After getting screwed over by so many partners at the age of 30 when I convinced my wife to sort of sell any form of asset we had in order to conjure up some form of deposit to get my own restaurant. Yeah, back in 1998, yeah. Wow, that's impressive. What type of stuff do you guys serve there?
So, highly seasonal. Again, it moves from going into summer now, coming out of spring. It functions five days a week. It's one brigade. We're closed Sunday, Monday. And so it's sort of one team, one dream. And that's how you conceptualize something that can run for decades, because you keep it small and powerful. Right, I love that. And for a dummy like me, a Michelin star obviously is sort of like the, you know, gold medal of a restaurant. And one is great, two is better, three is the best.
14, you've had 14, is that right? Yeah, we've won, yeah, over the years. We've got currently just under 10, but three stars is the ultimate. We've got currently just under 10, but three stars is the ultimate. And it's not just about the pompous wine cellar and the thick linen and, yeah. It's about the food being consistent
and the food being immaculate. And it's not easy to get as Gordon, what he's not, what he's leading out is, it's so hard to get just one, let alone two, let alone three, let alone three. It's the most difficult thing to do. But like there are, I'm slightly smarter for some reason about hotel stars, like there are certain things
a hotel has to do in order to qualify for four stars versus three, five stars versus four. What is it that gets you a star? What is it that gets you two? What does that get you? Three. Sure. So the first star is based on consistency and good food.
The second star is a level of excellence that is very rarely found, again, with great service. And third star is, you know, it's utter perfection. But perfection every day. Not just when the head chef's there, it's on a daily basis, lunch and dinner. So go back to Russian Gordon Ramsay, we've only got 10 tables.
So everyone says, how do you maintain that? Because we cook 40 lunch and 40 dinners, 80 guests a day, but we're on what, 64 staff? You know, in that entire place. So you look at the restaurant. Yeah, but then you got your lease, and you got to pay overhead. And then how does it, so is it like a team
of these Michelin folks that kind of go around the world, they don't let you know that they're coming, I would assume, and they just kind of pop in every once in a while, and then like Ratatouille, like the Pixar movies. That's exactly that, I mean, they're all incognito, you never get to see or hear them. Maybe they'll introduce themselves once a year. And you know, they suspect.
It's nice to meet you, Goddard, and I will give you one star maybe. They don't, they say nothing. They just pay the bill. Can I have a quick word with the chef? How's it going? And they keep it very, very minimal. You know that.
Except for the big fat tire guy. Except for the big fat tire guy. He's hard to miss. He's the fat fucker that ate everything. By the way, you know, it is Michelin tires, right? As you know, Gordon will tell you. Oh, it's the to miss. He's the fat fuck that ate everything. By the way, it is Michelin tires, right? As you know, Gordon will tell you. Oh, it's the same company? So Gordon, will you tell the story of how they originated, right?
I would like to know. Yeah. And by the way, Gordon, before you get... You've had 17 Michelin stars. Thank you. 17. So Gordon, tell them how it started. So it's in the southwest of France,
and this company, as you know, was formidable for tires. And so they came up with the idea back in 1900 to sort of formulate this guide. So as you travel across France, you sort of stop off and you pick up and you sleep in these little hotels and they start sort of sprinkling stars over them. But it's the longest serving guide in the world. It's one of the most prestigious and it's a guide that you never get to know. So...
Isn't that amazing? Yeah, that is. So it started... I've only been once. I've been to one three-star Michelin restaurant and that was in Tokyo. I went to Giro. And...
Beautiful. Yeah, beautiful. And he made me my dinner in front of me, Giro. Wow. Yeah, the old boy. This was in 2015. That's incredible, the documentary's amazing. Amazing documentary. He's got the sons there,
but he won't hand it over to his sons because they don't think they're sort of competent enough. Have you boys, Sean and Jason, have you seen that documentary, Giro, Dreams of Sushi? No, I wonder what's it called? Giro, Dreams of Sushi, J-I-R-O. And he is an apprentice who's making that one special dish
that I think is a sort of a cake type thing. And he doesn't let him make it to serve. He has to be an apprentice and practice for 10. Five years. Five or 10 years. Five years to wash the rice and then 10 years to sort of get up to speed. It's insane.
No way. Yes, it's crazy. And that's the sort of level of perfection that it takes to become a three-star Michelin, three-star. Well, you have to really want to do it, yeah. But I'll be honest, once you get there, you've got to delegate, you've got to get it off your radar in a way that you bring the next tier of talent through.
Otherwise, you're going to get changed at that stove. Yeah, I want to get into like, where did you find, like who was your inspiration to be fearless? Because you're the, I mean, you're fearless in business, in your restaurants, be fearless. Because you're the, I mean, you're fearless in business, in your restaurants, in life. I mean, you just go and go and go and you attack life. It's crazy. Yeah, I think, I'll be honest,
I think that's growing up in poverty. In a way that, you know, coming from a counselor state, sort of deprived area, going to school with like holes in your trousers and your mum having to put leather patches on your knees, which then actually turned out quite cool. Getting called out by your mates because you're having to line up in the queue for dinner tickets because you didn't have the money to buy food. Mom and Dad, we never bought individual photos.
So we had to go for that family shot that all three of us together, that the school were paying for. So you were pulled out of class on the last day of those shots and made to feel so bad because they knew you weren't doing individual shots. And then you all got called out in the middle of the lesson. When did you know, when did you know, so growing up in that, when did you know that like, I'm going to make it out of here, I'm smart enough, I have the brain to get me out of my situation? Yeah, from that moment, yeah. Yeah, first off, as you know, I started in soccer,
so I had a really strong sporting background. At the age of 18, I got released from Glasgow Rangers in a way that I was in their academy. You played under 14 football, right? Yeah, under 14, under 16, under 18. Because I was so big and sort of lanky and fast, I sort of played two years above my station. So I was playing in a game, it was a friendly game,
pre-season friendly game, and I got involved in a horrific tackle, pre-season friendly game, I got let go, they told me they'd keep an eye on me, and all that bullshit that comes with a sorry goodbye. And then I got into a catering course, just a basic college course where I'd spend two days a week at college and five days a week in a local hotel. And that's how it started. And so football, but initially football really saved you,
would you say, from your situation early on? Yeah, I mean, yeah, exactly that. Because it sort of not just kept me out of trouble, but it got me into a level of discipline that I enjoyed. But most importantly, I excelled. You know, I really did. Yeah. We'll be right back.
And now back to the show. That's interesting you bring up the discipline because you are, and Sean said it, you're so driven, but you also come across as a very disciplined person. You, as I mentioned, you travel a lot. You have so many things on your plate, forgive the pun, but you do have so many things on your plate. And I wonder, do you attribute some of that to the discipline that you did learn early
on from being part of a team, from being involved in sports so heavily? Yeah, I mean, listen, restaurants are dangerous games, right? When you start indulging, when you start drinking, when you start sitting down with customers and you start opening a bottle of wine and you start looking for the second, third, all of a sudden you're then a customer. And so I've got that level of discipline that is not there to be indulged. for the second, third, all of a sudden, I was with friends and the last time I ate there, would you believe, was with Coop when he was filming Burnt with Bradley.
And we had dinner together and he said, do you come here often? I said, no, I'm embarrassed. What, of your success? No, not so much of the success. I'm just embarrassed about how plush this thing is because we never grew up with this. I created this, I worked for it,
but I don't want to indulge. I think that's the discipline coming back again. But having that opportunity to excel so early in soccer and giving yourself a sense of excellence, of now that you, well, once you came into a leadership position, did you find that you were eager to give that opportunity to your staff, whether they be a sous chef, prep chef, or, I mean,
how did that inform the way in which you led folks? Unselfishness. And the non-control freak in me. And I suppose, you know, getting to the very top and winning that third mission star, I grew up watching my mom handle three jobs, and she was a cook in a beautiful little restaurant in Stratford, Avon. getting to the very top and winning that third mission star. I grew up watching my mum handle three jobs and she was a cook in a beautiful restaurant in Stratford-Avon. After soccer practice I'd go there and prep the veg for her.
It was mainstream food, but she installed that work ethic in me early. I knew when I got to the very top if I didn't delegate at the age of 33 and teach beneath me in a way that you got everyone up to that platform, I would kill myself because it is that relentless. So one minute you're playing in the orchestra, next minute you're conducting the orchestra is those 25 chefs on a daily basis, you then have to teach quickly and offload what you've got to empower the others to get on that platform. You know, it's so funny, because oftentimes when you see,
especially when they cut the commercials together for your various shows, they sort of cast you as the guy who's coming, you're being really hard on the people who run the restaurant, and they're quite slow, and they're dumb, and you're smart, and you're the villain, or you're the star, but you're the villain, or you're the good guy, you're saving them,
but you're well- And I smart and you're the villain, or you're the star but you're the villain, or you're the good guy, you're saving them, but you're poor. And I think that there's like this, certainly before I had ever watched the show when I saw those things, the misconception I had was that that it was all ego and in fact, it's the opposite. You understand that you've actually got very, there's very little ego in it. You understand that the restaurant
or the business is the star and that everybody has to be on board, pulling towards making that thing succeed. Exactly. Otherwise, you've spent decades as a busy idiot. And I'll be honest. Seriously. Because you just spent, you know... Listen, the hours are unsociable, the money's shit on the journey up, like in any career.
And so you've got to value that process. the money's shit on the journey up like in any career. And so you've got to value that process. And so when I started realizing all these issues, it was about the lack of empowerment. You've got to get them on the same page. It's bloody frustrating when they're not listening, right? And kitchen nightmares, let's not forget, I don't rock up unannounced. They do ask me in there by the way. And they promised me they have cleaned up
before I got there and I'm thinking, holy shit, so you cleaned up and it's still a shithole. What was it like two weeks ago? Yeah, but the psychological journey that you take them on is so funny. One of the greatest one-liners you had was, you walk in there to somebody and you said, you're like a one-hit wonder, except your one-hit is fucking burnt.
LAUGHTER Jesus. I got accused once of bringing a mouse in my pocket. No way. I think it was outside Philly in a restaurant and there was a mouse running across the floor and I said, look, we're about to open the doors. There's a fucking mouse on table seven.
I said, stop it, you brought that in. I said, sorry, beg your pardon. He said, yeah, roll the cameras back. I said, what do you mean roll the cameras back? Yeah, play the tape. I said, what do you mean play the tape? I don't do that shit. Are you saying that I put this mouse in my, yeah.
I saw you shake your leg as you came through the door and you shook the mouse out of your ankles. That's Ratatouille, isn't it? Honestly, I swear to God. What's the grossest, without naming it, what's the grossest situation you ever walked into in a restaurant? It's every episode.
I know, but there must be one that's stuck with you that's like. Oh God. What is the situation you ever walked into in a restaurant? Oh God, I think recently I was in one restaurant, and you know, sort of the hot plate, the past, that's where everything comes to, right? And they had all these parfait jars up there with like rice and lentils and grains, and I thought one of those jars had smashed because it's full of all these little grains. And until I got up close personal, I didn't realize it was actually full of rat shit. And so I said to the chef,
hey, have you seen what's on top of the pass? This stuff could be dripping into the face. Well, it's not. I said, yeah, but it's rat shit. He said, yeah, I'm going to clean it. I said, but when are you going to clean it? He said, what do you expect me to do? Fucking shoot the rats?
I said, no, clean your shit hole. And so he was cooking food, serving it under the hot plate with all these little tiny turds that had dehydrated become like little bullets on top of the pass. Gross. Jason, Jason, God, this hurts you so much.
I can't, yeah. Yeah, another one-liner. Sorry, this is the last one. You said, it might have been recently, you said, you're so fucking useless, you make a bloody brick wall look intelligent. Sometimes, I don't even know if I'm coming out with them, you know that.
Sometimes it's just in the heat of the moment. Of course, of course. They push your buttons, man. Yeah, well what really does, and if it changes, let us know, but I would imagine that your button gets pushed when you see people really not kind of rowing in the same direction, like not really being a good team member, or is it lack of work ethic or concentration? What is it that really gets you? Laziness.
Yeah. Laziness. It's the worst thing anyone can bring into any of us. gets you. Lazyness is the worst thing anyone can bring into any restaurant. Especially when you're working hard and people around you aren't where you are. Exactly that. And there are so many tiny details. And I always consider 10 little problems become one big problem at the end of the day. But when chefs start cutting corners in our business, you're screwed. It's the beginning of the end. And also, hygiene. No, but seriously, you know, there is nothing worse than a sweaty fat fuck that comes out of that kitchen
and goes to the table and he's got dehydrated skin, he's got a beard that's untrimmed, he's sweating from the armpits, his fingernails are black, and he asks you, how was your fucking lunch? I mean, the worst question, the worst question, his fingernails are black, and he asks you, how is your fucking lunch? The worst question, first of all, you should never have sent that food if it wasn't good anyway, so don't ask that question. Secondly, it's a bad advert for the restaurant. And it's gross. And today's chefs need to be a lot more prolific, not just as a marketing tool, but just common sense.
And so I hate laziness, I hate slobs. I'm not good at that. Yeah, yeah, I've been around. What do you guys, I know what my pet peeves are when I walk into a restaurant, they're really pretty trivial. Do you guys have a pet peeve? Does it start with welcome in?
Well, first of all, welcome in. Welcome in. If I own a restaurant, well, I do, if anybody at the Queen Beaver says welcome in? Well, first of all, welcome in. Welcome in. If I own a restaurant, whoa, I do, if anybody at the Queen Beaver says welcome in, you're gone. I fucking hate that sort of faux folksy bullshit. And it's new, right? Isn't it just like a-
Have a day, it's like when you play golf, they go have a day, fuck off. Exactly. Please fuck right off. That took over for touch base and circle back. Circle back, yeah. Welcome in is gone, but also when a waiter says, so tonight chef is preparing, I'm like,
I don't know chef, so stop referring to, and chef is doing a braised beef again. Or it's going to be. It's gonna be, yes. It's gonna be put on a plate, oh is it? I hope so. Yeah, or soup of the day, what was it? Well, it's a roasted carrot and cumin,
and what was the soup of the day yesterday? Roasted carrot and cumin. And what was the soup last week? Roasted carrot and cumin. So it's soup of the fucking month. And isn't soup really just sauce? Can we dispel the whole... It really is sauce, right? It's salty, it's creamy. Like you can put it over a chicken breast. No, no, no, no, no. I mean, soups are magical. I remember going to Paris at the age of 22, I said to you earlier,
without a pot to piss in, and I had to become French. And not only was I running away from the hurt in soccer, but I just wanted to memorize myself in France and become French. And my first job on the Galmanger, the sort of starter section, was making this broccoli soup with goat's cheese ravioli. So they gave me these heads of broccoli and a pan of water. And I thought we'd need garlic, shallots, vegetable stock, but all it was was rolling, boiling, beautiful water,
nicely seasoned, the florets, the little flowers of broccoli, cooked for two minutes so we didn't lose the color. Then you drain those broccoli florets, and then from there you use the water the broccoli was cooked in, and you puree the broccoli and add the water back to it, and it's most natural, delicious, flavored broccoli soup. Two ingredients, broccoli and water.
And then of course it gets sent into the Premier League with those little tiny goat's cheese raviolis. And it was so beautifully done. So no, soup is not a fucking sauce. No, it's not. And Sean, just for Sean, broccoli is a vegetable. Yeah, hang on. It looks like a tree.
Yeah, it's got a pop tart flavor. All right. Now, Gordon, why, my mother is British and she was always sort of just like, well, you know, Britain was never really known for its great food, she would always say. Why is that, and I hear that it has changed now. Can you walk us through that?
Yeah, I mean, I got the piss and the Mickey taken out of me. Yeah, when I was in Paris in the 90s, because we had such a bad reputation. Yeah, it was like roast beef, fish and chips, mushy peas, and it was dreadful. It was gray, it was dark, it was fucking horrendous. Because it was heavily influenced from? I think it was the mining, the mining towns,
in a way that it was like meat and two veg, and it was that sort of uninspired way of cooking with just absolute crap. And so I couldn't wait to get out of the UK to go and sort of get on that journey and start searching. And so France was, it was this bedrock. You get birthed at a cuisine. And then from France I went to Italy,
from Italy I went to Spain, and then from Spain I came across and spent a year on this incredible yacht, traveling around the world, picking up multiple cultures. So now the UK is this stunning melting pot. We're central Europe, we're 26 miles away from France, and it's got some of the best, best food in Europe now. We can rub shoulders with the French.
We can rub shoulders in the US. And yeah, it's a nation to be proud of now. Not to get political, but do you think Brexit kind of is dulling the cuisine influence? I think it's putting a bit of a sort of wedge between those incredible countries. The crossover was beautiful. I love a wedge.
With blue cheese and bacon, sorry. Oh shit. So yeah, I never get into politics. I stay out of that shit because customers come to be neutral and to break bread without some chef spouting out. But the influence of all of those countries that are so close to England, I'm sure, helped to influence the cuisine there. Massively.
But no longer. Massively. What would you say, would you, later, Raso, explain if you can for our listener, when an Englishman describes having his dinner, his supper, his tea, and where they all fit, and what time of day they fit, and how they can be distinguished one from the other. Yeah, that's a great question. First of all, I went to school with porridge,
which is your oatmeal, right? We didn't use milk, we used it with salt. I remember my father saying to me once that you're going to be making your oatmeal with salt. And I said, dad, why then lunch is just a basic sandwich, and then you come home for your tea. And tea is a dinner, but it's called tea, because you never asked for dinner. Dinner was a posh word.
You went home for tea, and sometimes that would be a jam sandwich, sometimes that could be fish and chips, steak and kidney pie, but you had your tea. And back in those days, you just, you got what your mom served you, right? You never questioned that. Is that not traditionally at four o'clock?
I know, I think you're thinking of the sort of high tea, the afternoon tea. That's different. Oh, that's what I thought it was. Yeah, so yeah, tea's dinner. So you hear like a guy coming back, especially 50, 60 years ago, a guy would come back from, when they used to have the coal mines
and that's all gone now, but they'd come back and he'd say, you know, would come back, go home to have his tea, right, Gordon? Is that what it is? That's exactly that, going home for tea. Yeah. Does the United States, in your opinion, have elevated cuisine at all?
I mean, like, you're just- Oh my God, definitely. Yeah. Absolutely, definitely, without a doubt. Yeah, okay. I mean, you always have to go to the cities, like the big cities, to get it, right? Yeah, I think the biggest shock when I first came over here
years ago was just the size of the breakfast. Yeah. And then on the side of the breakfast, you've got a fucking fruit salad on your breakfast as well. So it turns into like a mini dessert. That's not the way you want to start the day, right? Oh my God. They say it's the most important meal of the day,
but it should be your lightest meal of the day. And then you build up to that. But chefs are notorious for sort of eating, because we graze. So everyone says, you're not eating? You're not hungry? No, we've just grown up grazing, because if you don't taste everything before it goes out,
then how do you perfect that level of utter, beautiful, stunning food? So we have small spoons, and so I can't go out and eat. I think, well, last time. So we have small spoons. And so I can't go out and eat. I think, Will, last time you saw me, you're just picking, you're not eating properly. Do you have an eating disorder? I'm like, no, no.
We just can't eat starter, apps, main dessert. Yeah, you did it, that's exactly right. You didn't go through the whole thing, you just now sort of little bits and pieces. Gordon, I work a bit in Atlanta and I'm always really surprised. Oh, here we go, plugging in Atlanta again. And excited about how great the restaurants are there.
What's the last city that surprised you in the States with its cuisine? I'd say Austin, Austin, Texas. Oh, really? Yeah, yeah. Powerful, oh my goodness me. And I mean, I'm just talking about barbecue. There's some incredible ethnic restaurants there
and from Filipino to great Greek restaurants and Japanese, Asian inspired, yeah, Austin, Texas. What other than naturally French cuisine, which is sort of almost like the sort of the granddaddy of them all in a way, and other than going out for that, what is the, what is your sort of guilty pleasure meal to go out for that you're like, just go and have a Chinese or whatever, you know what I mean? Yeah, I mean, you know, I spent three years training in France,
that's two years in Paris and a year down the south of France. And I absolutely adore France. It's just the French, I can't fucking stand. Don't worry, they're not listening. Do you speak French? I do, yes, I do. Do you speak Italian too and Spanish? Yeah, but not fluent. The French is where it's at and we still got Russians.
Gordon, I had a French waiter once say to me, I said, everybody else is ordering drinks. I said, I have a Diet Coke. And he goes, ah, American champagne. I was like, hey, fuck you. Fuck you, dude. They just have the most romantic ways of describing food. We have grilled cheese, cheese and toast.
They have fucking cote monsieur. We have mashed potatoes. They have pommes puree. We have apple pie. They have a d'artre au pomme. But it is good. It is delicious. So other than French cuisine, what's your guilty pleasure?
What's your thing that you're like, oh, I'm going to go and have that? Oh, God. I'm a big fan of In-N-Out Burger. I love burgers, honestly. Yeah, I do too. A great smash burger. I just love burgers.
I absolutely adore burgers. Did that just start, the smash burger? And what it is literally, you just make the patty not fat and juicy, you make it thin and little. Cameralized, yeah. And they smash it once. Social media has popularized it for sure.
And the bun, the bun too, right? So it kind of becomes a little bit more sort of dense. Like a sandwich, because whenever I would go to a hotel and order, it'd be gigantic, the burger, and you couldn't even get your mouth there, and then it was like a mess. They ask you how you want it cooked. Jesus, Sean, your blood pressure's going up, relax, okay?
They're going to fix the burger. But also you get a much better camera-ization on that smash burger because you roll it and then literally smash it immediately. The minute it's being pressed onto that griddle. And then literally 90 seconds each side, it's camera-ized, it's juicy. And you can do a double stack on that as well. And really identify the flavor that means. What dish are you most proud of?
What dish do you think you make because you make so many? What dish do you think you make really well? And it could be as simple as an omelette. What's the thing that you most proud of? What dish do you think you make, because you make so many, what dish do you think you make really well? And it could be as simple as an omelet. What's the thing that you do really well? In your opinion. There's two things. When we took over Clarities back in 2004, I sort of reintroduced the fillet of beef Wellington,
which is a showstopper. And that's just like your perfect sort of go-to. That's like beef in a pastry, right? Yeah, I love that. You know what it is? I don't think I've ever had it. I'll send you one. Delicious.
And then second is scrambled eggs. Scrambled eggs for me are so important. Because anything rubber, anything overcooked, undercooked, there's nothing worse, honestly. And then every time I see chefs put fucking eggs in a microwave, I scream. I just, oh no. Some of the best scrambled eggs I ever had in my life
was at the Hotel Georges Sainte-Franc. Oh, there you go. Amazing. Of course. And I asked the guy. They put a little cream in it, right? Well, I asked the guy, I said, how do you get them so soft and creamy? And I don't know if he's joking with me.
Go fuck yourself. Go fuck yourself. With just a dash of go fuck yourself. With all these questions, stupid Americans, shut up. You like to know the magic? In French it's fat foot foot. Yeah. Fat foot foot?
Yes. What does that mean? Go fuck yourself. Go fuck yourself. Wait, but so I don't know if he was joking, he said American cheese, right? And I'm like, no, that can't be. What?
I come home, listen to this, I come home, I make scrambled eggs soft scrambled eggs really slow be. I come home, listen to this, I come home, I make scrambled eggs, soft scrambled eggs, really slow, and I put Kraft singles in them. It's incredible. Let me tell you, let me tell you, I'm going to make it for you. It's incredible. Gordon just punched a hole in the wall.
It makes it sweet and creamy. Somebody once put a little cottage cheese in scrambled eggs. And it was pretty good. No, no, no. The secret behind any great scrambled egg is stopping the cooking. Because if you don't stop the cooking, they'll just overcook and turn into rubber. So it's a teaspoon of creme fraiche
or a little tablespoon of cream. And that just slows the process down. All right. Sean, he was fucking with you. He just wanted to keep you in America. He wanted you to go home and stay home. You know what the one thing I do like, here's my guilty pleasure eggs, I will say this. My guilty pleasure eggs in Southern California especially
and it is chorizo and eggs with a little bit of cheese. Yes, they're beautiful. I love these. Beautiful. Fantastic. And corned beef hash. Yeah, they get eggs. We can eat breakfast, lunch and dinner.
That's the nice thing about eggs. That's the simplicity behind eggs. And it's something I taught all the kids, our kids to make from the ages of six, great scrambled eggs. And is it true that the cholesterol in eggs has been dispelled? They're fine for you is what I hear?
Or what do you know? Yeah, it's the balance, isn't it? I mean, you don't eat that every day. So we'll do scrambled eggs maybe at the weekend, Saturday or Sunday. Okay. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show.
Wait, but go back to your kids, because you have six kids. Good for you. Six children, and I read that you missed the births of your first four kids on purpose, is that right? Well, hold on, you're going to get me into shit here. Let's make one thing absolutely clear, okay? I know, but my wife didn get me into shit here. Let's make one thing absolutely clear, okay? I know, but my wife didn't want me in there.
She said, first of all, I want my mom and your mom in here. You're not going to fucking see me in that state, okay? And nobody on that side of the curtain, get out of there. So that was her decision. I had to respect that decision. And then when I did finally arrive in the theater for our fifth baby, I fucking clapped like a wimp. And I blacked out holding Oscar in the air.
Yes. I was so fucked. Holding the baby? But they said, what do you want to listen to? It was coming through the sun roof. And so there was a lot of commotions going on. It was a C-section? Yes.
Yeah, yeah, I've been there. Did you call that the sun roof? Yeah. I've been for all three, all three of my sons. I've been there. Did you call that the sun room? Yeah. I've been for all three, all three of my sons. I said, oh, can you play Ed Sheeran? So they started playing Ed. If you turn up the volume, I can hear all these noises.
Turn up the volume. And all of a sudden, I saw two more doctors dive in. I looked on the floor and there was blood everywhere. Oh, God. And all of a sudden, they popped him out and then they came straight over to me and I went, whoa, whoa, whoa, shit. Yeah. And I sat back and then I clapped like a fucking idiot.
Oh, I was moving. My second son, they came through on the radio, you could just hear very low, young hearts be free to the house. Love that song. I know, me too, it was so bizarre. That's great. And then, Gord, how do you, forgive me for asking,
but I think it's incredible you have all of these business ventures, you just go, go, go, the drive, the ambition, Gord, how do you, forgive me for asking, but I think it's incredible you have all of these business ventures, you just go, go, go, the drive, the ambition, the success. How do you, what is your rules of balancing all of the family life and the work life? Yeah, that's a great question. So balance is critical. We got the right kind of support.
Every time we were filming throughout the US, the kids would come with us, and then we would take them out of school two weeks early, put them back two weeks late, so we'd do the sort of filming schedules throughout the U.S. She's an incredible police officer back in London. Oh, that's great. Then we have the twins at 25, Jack's a Royal Marine Commando, Holly's into her fashion. And then there's Matilda, who's 23,
who's literally just come back from culinary school, would you believe, in a beautiful school called Bally Maloe. I am a little bit miffed the fact that she didn't ask me to train her. Sure. She's gone off elsewhere to come back to the fold. Yeah, she's seen the shows, that's the problem. So it sounds like you made all your, did all your kids have, did they all work sort of as they were growing up
and have jobs and do things and have direction? Yeah, yeah. And you always make them fly coach or something? 100%. And I tried to explain to them what they could do with the money when they land, because we're all getting on and getting off together, so I understand the difference. And secondly, no disrespect, an eight-year-old or a 10-year-old, they don't need fucking business class or first class what they could do with the money when they land.
Oh, the bread's so hot up front. Here's a couple. I'll be right back. I'll be back in about an hour to check on you. Yeah. I know. I just said, turn fucking right and do not disturb us for the next 12 hours. You're really, you're doing them a service though. They're really, you're, because otherwise you're depriving your kids of learning how
to live life and how to do things if you don't, if you don't provide that for them, I think. Yeah. And also removing the hunger, right? Yeah. And so it's not about selling at school with A stars and A's everywhere. It's about creating individuals. Well, give them a direction of something that they want to do, right?
And values, Will. Give them the values, install those values, and they can't depend on the moment that. I'm not perfect at it, I'm not suggesting that I am. But I'm sure. You know, because I got Netchettes on the other line, they want to talk to you about your parents next week. No, but I mean, look, you've got your daughter,
you got her into directing and she came and worked on your show and you got her sort of into the thing and give an address to it. I got my kids are working this summer, they're teenagers, they've got jobs. Give them a start and then see what they do with it. Exactly, I want them to have an idea of what it takes to make their own living and take care of themselves.
I work at a furniture shop. We don't care. How many times? How's that mic still on? Fucking unreal, Gordon's here, and he's talking about his family. You're just trying to fucking face it. Trying to speak, let the guys, he's our guest.
I didn't know what I was doing. Gordon, how do you feel, you know, so the restaurant business, you know, you love, you killed it, and then you get into the television business, you know it, you love it, you're killing it. Is there a similarity between the two? Is there an appeal that is shared with both, or do you love one over the other,
or how does that all fit in for you? Yeah, that's a good question. I mean, I think it's the level of creativity, I think, that I enjoy most about the TV. I hate it when shows are cancelled, so I'm always a firm believer in taking your own show down first before you get cancelled. And so, there's nothing worse than when something gets cancelled.
So fuck it, I'll come up with a better idea so you don't take me down and replace me with that. Also, I think not standing still. I think that's one thing, growing up watching Mum handle three jobs. Even on Christmas Day, we wouldn't see her to 5 p.m. in the afternoon because I knew she was coming in from the night shift working in a hospital. So you grow up with that work ethic. And I mentioned it earlier, you know, not just the fear of not having it there one day,
but just the value you have, where you are, and how long it's taken to master your craft. And that crossover into the TV world is sort of hand in glove, because it's real, okay? The shows are real, I take it serious. It's not about light camera action. I'm not a big fan of the shiny floor stuff. I love the raw stuff, if I'm honest. Oh, Rob is mad at you for saying that.
So, he's always mad at me. He loves the shiny floor. I know, but even when we are on the shiny floor, I want to keep it real, okay? I want to keep it really real. Right, right. Are you able to just stop and enjoy the fruits of your labor and all the success?
I mean, because every time we talk about your shows and your work, you just, you love what you do and you go, like you said, you just go, go, go. Are you able to just stop and go, wow, look at this and actually vacation and calm down for a bit? And pat yourself on the back. Yeah, I'm not very good at patting myself on the back of my mind.
What I do do when I'm off, I'm off. Every six months there's either an Ironman or a marathon and so there's this sort of date that I build up to. My next Ironman is coming. It's an Ironman? An Ironman, it's a race. A Triathlon. Triathlon.
Oh, got it, got it. And so my wife competes as well. She loves it. We spend a lot of time together swimming, cycling, and running, and so we have that nice little balance. Do you have a first gear? Do you ever shift down? No, but I mean, a lot of people are scared of that level of exercise.
For me, it's a way of relaxing. I know it sounds crazy, but it is a way. Sean, is that what keeps you, is it fear? Yeah, yeah, yeah, just fear of exercising. Yeah. Might start sweating. Fear of exercising. Yeah, I don't want to sweat. That's impressive. What's your strongest sport or what's your weakest?
The swim and the bike are strong. No, everyone's tracers out over the swim. And to be honest, everyone overworks that swim to shave two minutes off their time, which is crazy. I remember sitting in the deep water start in Hawaii for Kona Ironman, and there's two and a half thousand athletes, we had to swim out 200 meters and then wade, you know, tread water for 10 minutes before the cannon went off at half five in the morning. and there's two and a half thousand athletes who had to swim out 200 meters and then wade,
tread water for 10 minutes before the cannon went off at half five in the morning. I thought, my God, it's like being alive, finding Nemo down here, the fish were everywhere. I started conjuring my deers for dishes, et cetera, and then I got out of the swim, super relaxed, and then onto the bike because I do relax when I train because I just get into that rhythm and I de-stress and I offload and then I'm uncontactable.
I think that's the most important part about shutting off. No one get hold of me. No one knows that. JB, you have a meditative quality to your workouts too. You like to run for six miles and be kind of non-contactable. I do, yeah. It's just nice, I think just the discipline, right? And it's solitary.
It's just you against your body, your will, your discipline. Yeah, I do enjoy it. Hey, Gordon, you mentioned your body, your will, your discipline. Yeah, I do enjoy it. Hey, Gordon, you mentioned your mom a couple of times. She sounds like she was a huge influence on you. Is she still with us? Was she able to see and appreciate your success? Yeah, mom's 78.
She's down in Taunton, southwest of England. My first ambition after winning our third mission in style was after selling our house to go and get that lease because the bank wouldn't back us. So that was the only tangible asset I had. After winning our third star, the first time we ever come into any money, I went and bought mum her first house. And so for her to have that in her 50s,
something that she's never grown up with, was just one of the most exciting moments of my life. We have so many similarities. Sean, you did the same thing. Yeah, I brought your dad a new set of tires, right? Because he really burned through those first ones getting the hell out of there. Real flat spot on there.
Oh, shit. And he ripped the rear views off, too, right? Shit, you guys. Honestly. Oh my God, I'm crying. While the wheel was spinning, he ripped the rear view mirror off, threw it out the window. I think he hit Sean and Tracy both in the forehead with it. Then the tires tracked up and off he went.
And we haven't been closer since. My God, honestly. Wait, Gordon, but so many similarities, we don't have to go into it, but my mom, super hard work, workhorse, like I learned everything from her, grew up really poor, five kids, dad was nowhere, and similar, I just have a lot of the same drive that you do, and it's just,
it's great to talk to you about all of that. I get I get it I get where you bought your mama house that would about my mom house so yeah I think yeah it's the best gift you could ever give by the way I've told the story a million I'll tell it later it's it's my mom I did this big moment for her I where I moved her into a condo. This is when you gave her the monocle? Yeah. No. My mom has one eye, Gordon. She had one eye, yeah. And so she, I moved into her condo and while I built her this big mansion for all of us to live in,
and she, and I had that big movie, that bus moment where I filled it, you know, with the furniture and the silver, literally she just had to bring her toothbrush, and she walks in and she was so shocked and so surprised she was crying her eye out. Mmm, mmm, mmm. And she, and she, she's literally touched the couch
and she said, I don't know that I would have picked out that couch but everything else is like that and that instead of like, and that, that really. All three of us have the same mom. That's mothers, that's mothers. That's crazy, I remember when she came to Clarities for the first time and she was like the guest of honor for the opening party and they put her upstairs in the penthouse suite
and the butler came in and said, Mrs. Ramsey, can I run your bath? And she said, certainly not. I can run my own bath. Thank you very much. I'm like, oh my God. Honestly. And then I flew over to LA and we got this beautiful house up in Bel Air Crest
and it's beautiful. The views are stunning. It's a dream. And she was looking after the kids while Tan and I went for a run, funny enough. I came back and I said, you OK? She said, yeah, I'm just wandering. You're the neighbors. I said, yeah, what's wrong with them? She said, no one's got their washing out.
I said, for fuck's sake, but no one hangs their washing out. Our neighbor for ten years was Stevie Wonder, who lived next door to us. And the sweetest guy, the sweetest guy. And mum didn't even know it was Stevie Wonder. And I'm like, mum, I had to sing her the fucking song. Oh, is that? I'm like, for god's sake.
I'll pop round and ask if you'd like a cup of tea. She said, no, no, no, mum. You don't pop round to your neighbor's house. You can't do that in LA. Security will take you away. I love that. No, so, by the way, you have a new show coming out which I'll completely watch called Gordon Ramsay's Secret Service.
Right? When does that come out, by the way? Like May? Yeah, just when does it come out? Maybe it's already out. Secret Service? May 21st. Fuck, sorry, I should know that. Rob's going to kill me. Okay, Maybe it's already out. Secret Service, May 21st, fuck, sorry, I should know that, Rob's gonna kill me. Okay, so it's already out by the time this comes out.
Why do you think, this is one of the dumbest questions, but I can't get enough of food shows, and what is the huge appeal? What is it that taps into people that are, why is everybody obsessed with watching how food gets made? Something we do three times a day, seven days a week, breakfast, lunch, and we eat. I know, but still, why would you want to watch somebody do it?
I think to make yourself feel better. And everyone wants to be better at it. Exactly that. So I think, you know, there's so much to learn about food. There's so much enjoyment to cooking and it's emotional. And so those emotions, as you know, run high. And Secret Service is everything I've learned over the last 20 years, working in the US, from talented producers to great creators,
is in this show. Yeah, yeah. I can't wait to see it. It looks so good. Can you guys cook at all? No, I can't even boil water. I can make slappy joes, that's it. But is it a farewell? Is it something that you, is it intimidating? No, it's one of those things every once in a while out of the blue it'll occur to me like, I should learn how to cook,
and then it goes out of my head and I don't think about it again. And I don't know what it is. No? Sean? No, it's just, it's like, I'm not interested. I'm, you know, I'll get like in the winter, I'll get into baking and I'll bring these guys like over stuff like that I make a lot of the times. And then once I get into the rhythm of like making cheesecakes and cookies and whatever it is,
I'm like, oh, I kind of see it, but it's the mess and then the cleaning up. And then the- Yeah, that's the thing that keeps me away from it. The ratio between the prep, the cook, the cleanup versus the eating and the enjoyment. It's such a small wedge of, you know, is the eating. I almost don't want to eat it after I make it.
I know, it's just so much time to clean it up and to prep it, I should get into that. And I also love the fact that there's a roadmap, like a recipe book. You can just like, it literally tells you step by step what you need to do to get what looks great and it's going to taste great. And you just, it's dummy proof.
But the fulfillment is immense, okay? When you get over those bumps and you see that thing on the plate, it's like, wow. But I will say- You can do it with your kids or, yeah. But I will say that the thing I do understand about what you do is when you do make something great and you serve it and somebody says,
that's the best blank or whatever I've ever had. There is like a ego boost that you're like, oh, I did that. Like that's, you know. It's a great payoff, but you can be taught, okay, all this bullshit about you have to be bought into it. Do you have an educated palate? And you know, do you have to be natural? Absolute bullshit.
How do I know from a, yes, yes, yes, yes. And so I'm a little bit different to a lot of chefs. I teach my chefs to taste first before we learn to cook from a yes, yes, yes, yes. I'm a little bit different to a lot of chefs. I teach my chefs to taste first before we learn to cook because if you don't understand how it tastes perfectly, you shouldn't be cooking it. and items on the plate, You want me to cook and wash up? Geez. Growing up around mum, there was no such thing as dishwashers back then. You just got in and dug deep and washed up.
But I am a very smart and tidy worker. I don't make a mess. And so I sort of clean down everywhere I go. A bit of OCD going on. So yeah, the kids are good at cleaning. Alright, a couple of rapid fires here because I know we've got to let you go. You're a car fanatic. What car do you drive? What car do you wish you had? Depends where I am, it depends who I'm with. Majority of the cars we have are all in this incredible hangar that we've just built.
Oh my gosh, that's amazing. I'm embarrassed about the collection. I've been collecting for over 20 years. Oh, wow. Don't be. The only way I really get to understand these cars is on the track. So three or four times a year we'll rent a track out. Wow. Truck them down there. I bring in makes. The only way I really get to understand these cars is on the track. So three or four times a year we'll rent a track out, truck them down there, I bring in mates. Silverstone? Silverstone and Thruxton are two big tracks. Thruxton is the biggest track in the UK.
And what's your favorite one to drive? Oh, it's like saying who's the favorite kid. I would say I still love that little Subaru Ghira Aston Martin DB4, or the Ferrari SP3 Monza, an extraordinary piece of kit. How many cars do you think you got? I think it's about 94. So you hate pineapple on pizza, I do too. What is the other shit that you can't... What's another thing that you absolutely cannot stand combined, food-wise? Fucking cold foams, man. When I see foam on a...
What's cold foams? Foam. When chefs start aerating stuff and putting foam on a plate. That's for your fucking chin. Shave with foam. Don't fucking eat it. And that disgusting, sticky, insepid balsamic glaze, I love. I'm with you. I don't like it either. It's too sticky and gross.
I hate that shit. And I think you already answered this, but the one food that you, if you had to live with one dish for the rest of your life, I think it would be a hamburger. Is that correct? It's always going to be a hamburger. It would be a hamburger all day long.
Hamburger. Same. Smashburger. With cheese? No, no, no, X. It'd be a hamburger all day long. Hamburger. Same. Smashburger. Smashburger. With cheese? No, no, no, no, no. Just a beautiful smashburger. Don't deter from the flavor of that beef.
Lettuce and tomato? No, no, no, no. Just the burger and the bread. And there you go. Are you serious? Nice. Really? Everyone puts lettuce and tomato.
No, they put lettuce and tomato on there to make you feel fucking better as if it's healthy. Right. Here's your salad. Olive one. We've become accustomed. I like yellow mustard. I've become a big proponent in the last five years of old school plain yellow mustard.
It's the best. It's so good. It's the best. In New York, they don't sell it. You can't find it anywhere. So frustrating. No, because everything is Dijon or some sort of version of there. I know.
It's like spicy whatever. Yeah. Anyways, talk about spicy. Gordon, you're the best. This is wonderful. It's been an absolute joy. It's such an honor to meet you. I've been such a fan for so long.
I really have watched every episode and I was just in the UK a couple months ago for a stretch and I found, and I never knew it existed, Kitchen Nightmares, it was Ramsey's Kitchen Nightmares before you came here to do it. And I was like, oh my God, it was a channel that had it on 24-7, I watched every episode of that. I just, I'm just, I love it, I love you, before you came here to do it. I watched every episode of that.
I love you, I just love everything you do. It's my one to go to every week when we download. It's an honor to have you. Thanks man, it's so good to see you. Thank you so much. Thanks, guys. Thank you guys. Thanks Sean, thanks Will. Bye-bye. Thank you, Jason. Bye-bye. Bye, buddy.
He barely thanked you at the end there, JB. Did you hear that? Like at the last thing he was like, oh yeah, thanks Jason. Couldn't remember the name. No. It's hard, it's a tough one. So, because he was going to say Justin,
like everybody else, right? He was going to say, thanks Justin. Right, I got one the other day. It had been a while. I'm so bummed because I'm such a, I really watch everything he does and I was so excited to bring him on and surprise you guys and there's like,
you're like, oh hey Gordon, what's going on? I was like, I didn't know you knew him. We saw, Jason and I saw him recently. Well sorry, we're not like some crazy super cooking show fan, freak. No, I didn't know you knew him. In fact, I've never seen one of his shows but I will now and I do enjoy a cooking in fact I've never seen one of his shows, but I will now, and I do enjoy a cooking show,
but I have not seen one. Yeah, no, it's so good. It's so good, it's so good, and he's... Well, I mean, like, who's like, he has so many... I walked through the airport the other day, and I saw this restaurant called Plain Food. P-L-A-N-E. I was like, oh, that's clever, it's Gordon Ramsay.
Yeah, there you go. And an airport. And an airport of all places. He's got a restaurant. I mean, he's just. Yeah, he's doing very well. You gotta do well to buy 93 cars, okay? Yeah, yeah.
It's insane. 93. Did you say 94? I think he said 94, yeah. Did you say 94? Yeah, I'm pretty sure he said 94. He just bought another one. God, good for him, you know?
I know, I know. Yeah, he's great, I love him. I'd love to go to his, where'd he say it was in Chelsea? Yeah, in Chelsea, let's go, let's go, you know what? Let's go see Shaunie's play. Yeah. And we'll go for dinner there. Let's do that.
And then what about when you're in England doing it? Yeah. No, it's in Chelsea, New York? In London, I think, isn't it? Oh, oh great, okay. Yeah, well, I mean, it's, yeah. Let's do it. Let's do that.
Bradley's been there. Yeah, okay. How about that? End of story? Yeah, I mean, just like that he's held out on us. We didn't know that, I didn't know that he'd been to this three star, three Michelin star. Right, we'll go to the restaurant. Yeah.
We'll sit down. I guess we can. We'll have, we'll have. I'm trying to the restaurant. Yeah. We'll sit down. I guess we can. I'm trying to look for one. It's rare that he doesn't build up, so let him build up. I know. I'm like letting him... We'll sit down and we'll just have a nice quick bite. Bite!
Bite! Bite! That was good. Thanks, man. That was really good, yeah. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Granteri. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.